my partner and I make a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars combined y'all
tell me why just why am I still living
paycheck to paycheck you're stupid and
lazy
you know what we gonna end it there
let us know what you guys think do you
agree or disagree why
pays like a decent amount of money like
very median very average but like I
should be able to live on this this is a
good salary good salary not anymore
not anymore
like I've started to dread going to the
grocery store to buy tin foil because
off brand weak ass tin foil is like 10
bucks I saw an 18 pack of eggs
for 13
I I walked in to the to the Walmart
like a few days ago I bought standard
Necessities Ziploc bags tin foil eggs
some some [__] blindled pasta because
I can't eat the real stuff and that has
good protein in it a singular pound of
ground beef
milk eggs
cheese tell me why I walked out of there
having spent 70 dollars
seven d seven zero
my partner and I make a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars combined 120
that's good that should be okay like we
should be set took a lot of work and
effort and resume building and all the
good stuff to get here why are we both
living paycheck to [__] paycheck this
is not
sustainable
we're
uh how are people going to find a place
to live how how are we supposed to
continue to eat like forget about me
because we're still living
we're kind of making it like it's it's
not as horrible as it could be but what
about these these young kids trying to
start alive trying to get out of their
parents house there you go there you go
see what she did there she did what she
did there and that's the end right so
the problem is she said why are we still
living paycheck to paycheck she said
that right
and then she tried to link it with the
food if you're making a come by income
of a hundred twenty thousand dollars and
you're living paycheck to paycheck is
because you're making bad decisions
don't link it to food yes the food is
pricey but there's a lot of bad
decisions that you make I'm not saying
that trying to [__] look at you and
be like hey you know what yeah
I make I made bad decisions as well
we're in a spending habit where we spend
we spend we spend we spend we spend we
talk about environment and we tweet that
[__] on a brand new iPhone that we
bought the second one that we bought
today because we crashed the other one
because we don't really take care of a
[__] if you're making 120 a year and
you're living paycheck to paycheck and
you that means that you don't have a
plan you didn't establish a plan don't
link it all to food yes I believe that
food is [__] up in some certain prizes
there's some surges but if you're you're
doing a 120
you have to ask other questions than
just the food don't blame it on food
like Abba said you can get a lot of [__]
on Amazon she's a 120 and they live in
paycheck to paycheck
crazy that's the thing that's crazy the
food thing is another thing altogether
it's another thing and I get you but
don't link it do not link it to food
there's another problem there's
something else if you're living paycheck
to pay that's something else the food is
one thing
but if you're saying you're living
paycheck to paycheck nah be okay there's
some other underlying issue okay I
sympathize a lot all right like I said
up until two years ago your boy was
struggling all right making less than
35k a year
doing self-employed work it's good
enough for me because I get my costs low
but I understand you go to the grocery
store you look at certain Meats you're
like not today not every [__] this
[__] is efficient okay this
[__] I gotta switch out money
I gotta look at y'all I'm not gonna lie
and say Yes times are hard but are you
doing anything to help yourself
everything is a balance between the
system and the individual people who say
everything's systemic no [__] some of
it's individual Choice okay and it's a
mixture of those two things
[__] taking out 200 Kane
student loans to go be a [__] I'm not
a [__] nothing a [__] a [__]
nothing how many people work in their
feet biologists which
what is that which I don't know neither
do you ain't nobody gonna pay you stupid
[__] nothing okay
we gotta make more sensible decisions if
you are living paycheck to paycheck on
120k I have to imagine there must be
some crazy students I got questions
there must be some like some people told
me like I remember this like most
Americans have their credit cards maxed
out and they're making minimum payments
or something like crazy like that I was
like what the minimum payment is as
stupid as [__] you could do on a credit
card absolutely someone someone told me
someone told me that poor people use
credit card for the money they ain't got
yes rich people use credit cards for
their points
that's all right credit card is at zero
every single month and this is not now
this has always been my case One credit
card and I used to pay every single
month in full you know I think I
couldn't pay it off I will not touch it
okay I use my credit card because it was
necessary for things it wasn't so I
could go buy [__] new shoes all the
time so all the times [__] look at
that yo why you look so broken and Dusty
it's because that's what I can afford
I'm not going to be out here pretending
okay maybe I could have squeezed in some
dollars over here and there to go to the
thrift shop but I'm just saying
I lived my means
some of y'all want to pretend you're in
a different stratosphere going to the
club buying drinks when your ass can
only afford sobriety
how you an alcoholic [__] you too poor
that's why you homeless taking it up the
butt to get drinks okay let's be honest
y'all doing shady [__] to admit these
things because you can't afford it y'all
taking on addictions you should have
never been partaking in to begin with
I'm too broke to be an addict that's
been my truth
I can't afford to pay for this [__] like
listen bro I got bills to pay I can't
afford it because I got to be
functioning to go to work so I can't
smoke weed I can't afford none of this
stuff and so I acknowledge it and I
lived according doesn't mean I wasn't
able to enjoy myself or find things that
I could invest my money in but I try to
make sure it works for me when I hear
120k combined income what we are living
paycheck tip I don't care where you live
you can live in San Francisco you are
lying you're lying you are alive
well my rent is seven move a little
further there's no reason even in San
Francisco you're paying 7K I don't care
there's choices that you make man it's
choices that's your name bro and that's
where they're not and that's where she
got me that's I understand the food
thing but that thing is not related
listen my man's right here I Gotta Give
the props You Gotta Give Caesar what
belongs to Caesar this mother effort
right here is efficient
efficient
with his money he can stretch a whole
dollar a whole lot it all comes down to
what is he a magician in some kinds of
way yeah but not with the money it's the
choices I look at I look at Abba the way
Abba move and the way I've seen Abba
move from the and sometimes from time to
time I make fun of him because he's
dusty but for real for real for real for
real this [__] don't care he
don't care his money in check he's
always good I
it really that it's really that
you got a gift to Caesar what belongs to
Caesar this guy this is probably one of
the smartest dude that I've seen with
his money
outside of my mom
and my mom is smart with her money but
this and it all comes down to the
[__] choices you made yeah I gotta
comes out sometimes you gotta put
yourself bro you gotta humble yourself I
cannot I was still traveling at the time
I was traveling twice a year well how do
you afford that with that small income
guess what choices I make choices what
do those choices look like I go to
cities where I got friends
why because staying on a couch saves me
a grant
easy
I try to fly on a weekday why because
the tickets are half the price of the
weekend yeah I'm saying all of these
things
because when I hear people talk like
this they want to complain about the
state of the world today not
acknowledging any of the
responsibilities that they have for
their financial situation whatsoever and
I'm sympathetic in some regards because
I feel like financial literacy is
something that people should be teaching
us be it our parents be it um be the
system itself being education like
that's the mission that they teach us
about debt what that actually like my
only lesson and I say this on the
Channel all the time that my mom taught
me financially is she said don't keep
any debt do not be paying no interest if
you got debts Google if you can't afford
it don't buy it and I live by that my
whole life
I live by that and that's not maybe the
greatest business decision or whatever
but I use it for me as a person
individually that worked well for me I
never had to look at my savings and see
zeros everywhere
cost of living rent whatever
even though rent is relatively cheap
here and you think I moved into a place
by myself why why would I pay
two grand three grand when I could be
paying 500 a month and have a roommate
or two
yeah
like you know like you make these
choices based off the situation that
you're in and you try to live
accordingly to bring down any of those
costs you got to go live home with your
parents again you do what you got to but
folks living paycheck to paycheck
sometimes I look at them like why are
you here at the club Millennials are
ordering out more than ever they're
ordering Foods more than ever they can't
cook
they can't cook and they check the
paycheck you spending two grand a grand
on ordering out every single time
cooking there's no doing like bulk
cooking you would save maybe five to
seven eight hundred dollars a month and
that's on the low end
I'm not mad if you can afford it you
want to do that do that but people
making these choices I'm looking at them
crazy like how much is a pack of
macaroni a pack of pasta rice listen the
internet is there if you're telling me
and that's probably why she took it down
because she's getting dragged if you're
telling me you're out of a combined
income of 120k and you living paycheck
to paycheck it's these two things
you're stupid and lazy
you know what we're gonna end it there
let us know what you guys think do you
agree or disagree